we've got quite caught up in the concept
before so I just really want to even
though I know and I say a lot
mathematics is not about the processes
of algorithms at the same time I want
you to master the processes and
algorithms because then you can focus
mentally like you can have some critical
thought and worried about what's work
for you so here's the question it's a
very simple setup square root of x y
equals x cubed they want the area
between those and maybe you want to
start drawing your diagram now because
the diagram and its construction is one
of the key skills i want you to develop
right now the area between those is this
here and as you can see by my error
which I've already put up there we are
going to be rotating around the x-axis
okay so haven't got the area I want and
this is the rough outline at the shape
i'm going to get when i do my revolution
I want to do this by cylindrical shells
clearly I could do this by annular
slices as well but I'm trying to
rehearse this new skill so here's what's
going to happen what's the key
difference between cylindrical shells
and all these by slicing what four key
difference it's a difference of
direction what is it okay yes so I'm
looking to use the word slices can i'm
not going to get slices right now but
the strips the area that i'm going to
rotate ears they're parallel they're
parallel to the axis of rotation rather
than perpendicular to the axis of
rotation i used to saying that have that
language you don't want to be in that
point real lightweight what am i doing
again if you can't articulate it of
course you're gonna have trouble doing
it so here's what i've got at the moment
i'm sort of struggling for colors here i
use a lot more colors windows drivers
but here I've got four so I want you to
put in one of these strips write
something like saying this okay so there
is one of my stereos parallel to the
axis of rotation and I'm going to rotate
it around and hopefully get a
cylindrical shell so it looks something
like let's see here it looks like it's
gonna be rough
here there's the opposite side right and
you must must absolutely draw a
cylindrical shell that corresponds to
something on your diagram okay how does
it look are you convinced yes it's a
pretty busy diagram which is why it's
got to be big okay I've said before I've
talked about the palm rule for these I
kind of think for any volume by slices
or cylindrical shells I'd go hand man
seriously look at look at how busy my
diagram is and my one's huge okay so
there's my David now I need some piece
of information on this for the volume of
a cylindrical shell and the easy part is
to work out the thickness of it that's
going to be something like this which
axis is my thickness going on it's the
y-axis right because it's parallel here
so this is going to be up Delta Y ok
what else have I got here I'm going to
need a radius what orientation is the
radius it's also why so in fact this
distance here the radius of my cylinder
r is just equal to whatever y coordinate
i am at so that's nice the last part is
the trickiest because of the orientation
I've got it's a height here now what
I've tried to do by putting my graphs y
equals the square root of x and y it was
X cubed in different colors is to try
and highlight to UK which one is which
to get this high tea are clearly as a
difference right it's a subtraction of
one from the other okay what do I
subtract away from what which ones which
remembering that I am on a horizontal
answer to you right this is going to
this black curve I've just highlighted
this x value is going to be bigger where
is this blue one over here this x value
is going to be smaller do you agree so
in other words i want the horizontal
black value take away the horizontal
blueberry yes you see where that the
problem the tiny program i have if i
don't have the x-coordinate as a like
it's not the subject of these equations
so I need to make it the subject right I
need to know for the black one what's X
equal to and then for the blue one
what's X equal to thankfully not that
hard what is it the black one cubed x
yeah you need so I keep your white favor
and then for the blue one the smaller
what it's just going to be yeah cool
that's not so hard okay so I've got my
diagram I'm pretty much ready to go now
okay so the way I actually stated of in
by working is I say for this cylindrical
shell because as you know if you're
doing it by slices I'm hopefully the
diagram is good enough you can see but
there's a radius and height on a slice
as well so if I say this right that it's
very clear what method I'm taking for
this Sullinger so the radius is just
equal to the height of my coordinate and
the height of each shell is going to be
black takeaway blue nice and easy that's
the cube root of Y take away y squared
are you happy with that so now I'm ready
to say okay what volume is and therefore
add a whole bunch are so therefore the
volume is equal to the limit of okay
what's changing Delta Y is approaching
zero okay therefore since everything in
terms is in terms of wise right because
that's the access i'm looking at i'm
gonna need Y values here right so I
actually need to know from here all the
way up where do I end okay now these are
very easy graphs maybe you could tell
where do you think the X cubes and
ex-cons me it's going to be 11 isn't it
so in fact I'm going for y equals zero
that's the smallest one up to 10 k and
then what happens in here well this is
going to be 2 pi RH right which in this
case is y times the cube root of Y minus
y squared yeah so that's my 2 pi RH I'm
missing one piece the thickness of my
cylindrical shell come and that was all
the hard part's the visualization
they're working out which bits which and
how they interact and from here it's
actually very very straightforward I'm
now going to turn this I'm going to turn
this into an integral now rather than by
Sigma notation and while I'm at it I'll
do some simplifying so my to play that's
constant comes out this guy's not 21 I'm
still going to leave this as a product
but instead of writing the cube root of
why I want to make it easier for my
integration so in fact that's why to the
power of a threat third minus y squared
and that's a dy they are rather than a
delta cuz I've been training and in here
I just index logs yeah just in
businessman so that's why to that or
thirds and cool integral
hold on hold on how it goes up first bit
to become seven on three and then I've
got to / that power so there's a three
on seven at the front yep take away why
the four and four or quarter what are
the forces simple format from not 21
this is nice two pi times yep and I've
already crushed this i'm pretty sure
you're going to get five on 28 in here
and there's a two there yeah so five PI
on 14 and I'm working out a volume some
done okay so you can see it's really
nice if you know how to do cylindrical
shells the algebra comes out simpler
because there's squaring that you get to
avoid that's really great okay and
what's your master it's like up okay
this is not so bad it looks a bit
intimidating when you see this and when
you see that but i kinda seemed not that
different because you'll be getting more
familiar with what's under the power
okay